I'm just arrived in Malaysia
first time Malaysia yeah really happy
the place is amazing
more modern than I expected I'm in
Penang when I'm starting my culinary
mystery tour to master the art of
Malaysian cooking and I've got a hell of
a lot to learn what do I know about
Malaysian cuisine three dishes satay the
most prominent rang dang and laksa
that's it
my home for the week has been a
destination for Chinese and Indian
immigrants for hundreds of years it's a
melting pot of people and food and so
Asian fusion is the order of the day
[Music]
I'm always excited not just learning the
you cuisine but understanding how it
came together where it originated from
and for me what can I take away to set
me off on my trip I've got a dinner date
in Penang thank you with one of the
country's top chefs Audie Chia Ollie hey
all he's been cooking Malaysian top
restaurants for 20 years but tonight
he's hosting a special dinner party at
home it's a big party tonight
what for a pre-reading party nice who's
getting married I am getting married
what's the lucky lady's name her name is
Chu Hong chu Hong yes fantastic you'll
meet her tonight I cannot wait Vicki
Jose Blaine you want to come yes please
have a look I'm expecting to learn from
an executive chef but there's a surprise
awaiting me in all these kitchen this is
the chef this is my mom ah I'm confused
now why aren't you cooking for your
party because all the chefs in Malaysia
their favorite chef is the amount so can
i things you cook at work I cook western
Mediterranean restaurant pastas what
what must us yeah western fierce
Mediterranean pasta yes I'm here to
learn Malaysian choosy
the best person to learn from my mom
yeah call her aunty Ken on two cats
ticket why the chorion see I got in make
sure everybody would call an elderly
auntie everybody who's elderly yeah
becomes auntie auntie is running the
kitchen and her son is kept firmly in
the background what is that dude that is
not you that is not you you've had it
shocked no taste
even the chefs love who's that on the
fridge well that's in Mosul you want to
other go with that no I don't want it
autograph Howdy's in charge your faces
everywhere okay
it seems women may be the inspiration
behind Malaysia's food so I'm gonna
stick with aunty this is my first chance
to taste Malaysian fusion she wants to
show me a chinese-style pork dish
that's and this is us small - or large -
flash - yes auntie a little bit more Oh
for me I like oyster sauce right so we
get I'm very trying easy aren't we yeah
a little bit little bit marinated so we
marinate that now why was last time
already cooked this for you I don't like
his teeth so you don't like his taste
that's incredible and you're supposed to
be an executive chef now smells amazing
all that garlic yeah take it we don't
kiss after dinner my introduction to
Malaysians fusion has been a surprise
Chinese ingredients an executive chef
who takes orders from his mum I can't
wait to meet the lady who's agreed to
marry Penang's pasta king
he's point fiance
Wow excuse me I mean amazing you lucky
man what was it that attracted you first
to old him what was it his food or yes I
cook them in pasta
you keep stop mentioning that word pass
in front of your mother that's delicious
really good it's so tasty when he moves
out can I move in yeah I'll pay trust me
just in terms of learning attitude
what's taking place is a fusion they've
got a Chinese influence across the
Malaysian style but a little bit spicier
than I expected but bloody delicious I
mean really good I think the only way to
really start peeling back these layers
of the authentic Malaysian cooking is to
spend more time with the ladies
the aunt is at home off the beaten track
stay out of the restaurants stay away
from groups of chefs and yeah spend more
time with the artists I'm heading off
but not before already gets his own back
from my past there gags he wants to make
sure that I see for myself how tough my
lazy and aunties can get since we've
been talking about auntie's the hoarding
yes you know nick is the one completion
coming up in KR : lumpur with the
auntie's already are they all as good as
your mother somewhat better yeah okay
and what's the idea of the competition
it's to cook our national dish I love ya
competition clearly want me to go in yes
that competition yes thank you thank you
for a real picture
tomorrow might venture around Malaysia
begins that if I survive the night
is it safe okay take your seat take my
seat yeah or not because I gonna get
caught speeding this are we okay sit
down so that wait wait wait wait what's
the bike
[Music]
how long you been driving Oh 50 years 50
years yes
from 1959 what yes 50 years yeah
ready careful careful careful careful no
no nice okay don't order what I think my
hand yeah we have to signal
probably those doing this